Look to your left.
Now, to your right.
Wherever you are,
whatever you're doing, it's safe
to say you're surrounded by matter.
That's because matter makes up
just about everything in existence,
from stars and galaxies
to planets to puppies and pizza.
But matter has a rarely seen
rival: antimatter.
For every type of matter particle,
there is an antimatter doppelganger
with the same mass
but the opposite electric charge.
An electron has a positively charged
counterpart called a positron.
A proton's antiparticle is an antiproton.
You get the idea.
So why did matter win out?
Why aren't there
puppies made of antimatter?
The universe didn't have to be this way.
The Big Bang is thought to have made
matter and antimatter in equal amounts.
These opposites annihilate when they meet.
So you'd expect the universe
to be a bleak, lifeless wasteland
filled with nothing but energy,
but somehow matter won out.
I'm going to tell you a story
about how a tiny, unassuming particle,
the neutrino, and its hypothetical
relatives
could explain the existence of, well,
everything.
[VIDEO GAME MUSIC]
Neutrinos are super weird
subatomic particles.
I'm kind of obsessed with them.
They have ridiculously tiny masses,
and they're often called ghost particles
because they are so ethereal
that they can pass through
the entire earth without leaving a trace.
There are more neutrinos than any other
particle with mass that we know of.
They are produced
in the sun, in radioactive decay
and in other reactions
throughout the cosmos.
But their stealth makes them
very hard to study.
For something so common,
we know shockingly little about them.
And these mysterious particles
might be even stranger still.
Many physicists suspect
that in the early universe,
heavy relatives of today's neutrinos
proliferated.
Those early neutrinos, the origin story
goes, helped bring about the matter glut.
OK, stick with me.
It gets complicated,
and it might sound counterintuitive.
It turns out in order to create today's matter,
you have to first create extra antimatter.
[EXPLOSION SOUND]
Here's how scientists
think it might have gone down.
The heavy neutrinos decayed
into antimatter
particles more often than they decayed
into matter particles.
From there, a physics process
called a sphaleron possible
only in the newbie universe took over.
Like a cosmic cheat code,
the sphaleron process converted
the newly formed excess of antimatter
into an excess of matter,
specifically quarks, the type of particle
that makes up protons and neutrons.
So to recap,
heavy neutrinos made extra antimatter.
Then that extra antimatter
flipped into matter.
And that's how many physicists suspect
we got the matter filled universe
we see today.
But scientists don't know if that's
what really went down.
This all would have happened at conditions
too extreme to reproduce in a lab.
So how can scientists confirm the story?
That's where today's neutrinos come in.
If the heavy neutrinos really did decay
unevenly into matter and antimatter,
then physics probably also treats
today's neutrinos
differently than their antimatter
particles, antineutrinos.
So scientists are looking to modern
neutrinos for clues.
Researchers are focused on
one of neutrinos' strangest
abilities: changing their identities.
Neutrinos come in a menu of three flavors:
electron, muon and tau.
But these flavors aren't locked in.
Neutrinos oscillate between flavors.
A particle might be born
as an electron neutrino,
but when scientists measure it,
they might find a muon neutrino instead.
Scientists want to measure
how often neutrinos oscillate
and compare
that with antineutrino oscillations.
If the two don't match,
that means physics does
treat neutrinos
and antineutrinos differently.
That matter-antimatter
mismatch is something physicists call
charge-parity violation or CP violation,
and it's a necessary ingredient
in the story of how matter came
to dominate the universe.
To catch enough of these ghostly particles
to compare how neutrinos
and antineutrinos oscillate,
physicists are building giant detectors.
The Deep Underground Neutrino Experiment
or DUNE
in an old mine in South
Dakota will spot neutrinos
interacting
with the liquid argon inside the detector,
allowing scientists
to determine the flavors.
DUNE ultimately plans to use a detector
so big that the liquid inside
could fill nearly 20 Olympic
swimming pools.
Another neutrino detector
called Hyper-Kamiokande in Japan
will also be huge, filled
with 260,000 metric tons of water.
It will be lined with 40,000 light sensors
that will spot dim flashes produced
when the neutrinos interact
with the water.
Both detectors are being built
deep underground, using the earth
above to filter out other particles
that can interfere with measurements.
Particle accelerators will create
beams of neutrinos to be sent across
hundreds of kilometers,
giving them plenty of time to oscillate.
The scientists will compare
the neutrinos' oscillations
with those of antineutrinos
sent on the same trek.
If the neutrino and antineutrino
oscillations don't match,
it's a hint that the heavy neutrino story
could be true.
But it wouldn't be the last word.
Neutrinos are a particle
that's close to my heart.
Literally.
Trillions of them are streaming
through my body
and through yours at every moment.
As they speed through me,
I like to imagine
giving them a word of thanks,
possibly for all of existence.
You should have had a burrito beforehand
[laughs].
Ehhh.
[laughs] I should have gotten you a burrito.
Actually, my burrito wasn't very good,
so never mind.
OK. What was I saying?
Be sure to like and subscribe
to see more videos like this one.